here are some simple grammar notes to
help you
through this lesson uh let's first of
all look at verbs
and there are uh verbs are action words
so when we see the expression command
allevo which means how are you
in fact the franchise the french say how
are you
going so ale is to go
vous vous how you go
and the answer is so this is the same
verb
except here it's you and here it's
i so we notice that the verbs change
depending on the
person whether it is
now how can you remember how the verb
changes
the verb allay to go in the present
tense
that's an awful lot to remember you'll
only gradually get used to it
and start remembering it but remember
you can always
google any verb you can google
present tense valet you can google
french verbs you can google
verb alley and you will find all of the
tenses
and all of the forms of the verbs get
used to using
google so when we see the next question
what is your name we have the verb there
it's
a which is a form of the verb etre which
of course you need to find out
but you can google it you can google the
verb et you can probably google
the verb verb est
now let's move a bit on to nouns you'll
see that we say bonjour
and that's an immediate clue that jewel
is masculine because in french they have
gender masculine and feminine on the
other hand
when we see bun nui that tells us that
me night is feminine
the same here with no no
and that tells us it's a masculine noun
the same is
what is your name because if it's
feminine
it would be ma and the kel
would have e-l-l-e there so that's
something to look forward to but this is
just
a brief start to some aspects of verbs
and nouns
in french